it all begins with a few rough pencil
sketches and ends up a quaint living
room or a giant City the art director
draws on imagination and research to
bring to the big screen visions of what
is and what could be these are the five
films that have been nominated for this
year for art direction the power of
television journalism in the 50s in the
climate of fear created by Senator
Joseph McCarthy was the backdrop for the
art direction of nominee Jim Bissell and
the set decoration of nominee Jan
Pascale and good night and good luck it
was back to Hogwarts for young Harry
Potter as he and his companions found
themselves in the magical often
frightening art direction of nominees
Stewart Craig and the set decoration of
Stephanie McMillan in Harry Potter and
the Goblet of Fire the mighty king Colin
was able to roam the jungles of Skull
Island and the depression-era streets of
New York thanks to the art direction of
nominee grant major the set decoration
of nominees Dan henna and Simon bright
the final days of the golden era of
Japanese geishas were meticulously
recreated in the art direction of John
Mayer and the set decoration of Gretchen
Rao for Memoirs of a Geisha
jane austen's account of love and
misunderstanding in eighteenth-century
rural England is succinctly captured by
the art direction of nominee Sarah
Greenwood and the set decoration of
nominee Katie Spencer in Pride and
Prejudice and the Oscar goes to John
Mayer for Memoirs of a Geisha and for
set decoration gretchen Rao
this is the second Academy Award and
third nomination for John Mayer the
first Australian and second nomination
for Gretchen Rahul
well thank you very very much oh I'm
really lucky to share this award tonight
with a really lovely lovely woman our
set decorator Gretchen rau who
unfortunately couldn't be with us here
tonight and she asked me to read a
little note Gretchen wishes she could be
here with all of you she thanks everyone
with whom she's collaborated in her work
and her life she loves you all
Gretchen our thoughts and prayers are
with you tonight
I'm sure Gretchen would also like to
thank our brilliant director Rob
Marshall because this really is his
movie every single frame of it so thank
you for letting us be a part of it and I
want to thank my team my whole crew but
that led by the team of Tomas Roth John
Hoskins clyde zimmerman thank you very
much and thank you to my agent Sandra
Marsh who got me here thank you